easy to apply cheap and effective
glyphosate destroys all unwanted
vegetation the only things it leaves
growing are the crops it's meant to
protect marketed under the name roundup
the herbicide is a bio Monsanto product
it's in use on 40% of Germany's farmland
it's also used in over 150 countries
worldwide since it was introduced in the
1970s over 10 million tons of glyphosate
have been sprayed on crops enough to
fill 2,300 Olympic swimming pools that
makes it the most widely used weed
killer in the world it's also the most
controversial Environmental Protection
activists blamed glyphosate for the
disappearance of many plants which once
grew wild in nature and a corresponding
loss of bird and insect populations and
they say it trickles down into the
groundwater scientists have found traces
of glyphosate in humans which has crept
into the food chain the World Health
Organization classifies glyphosate has
probably carcinogenic to humans let's
get more on this story now with Heidi
hotarla one of the lawmakers in the
European Parliament who had filed a suit
she joins us from Brussels miss Halle
thank you for joining us on DW the
European Food Safety Agency according to
today's ruling now does have to release
the studies on glyphosate so that must
be a victory for you did you get what
you wanted yes yes we actually got more
than we expected because it's a total
victory in the key questions there's an
overriding public interest which goes
above the commercial interests of the
companies in terms of disclosure so
Health and Environment are more
important than companies financial and
commercial interests this is wonderful
and then the court actually defied
defined the emissions into the
environment which was a bit of a key
element in in the dispute as real that
not something which will be just
hypothetical so we have a landmark
ruling also on the Aarhus convention on
public access to environmental
information which now confirms that when
a substance is released into the
environment by virtue of its function it
will have real emissions and they have
to be covered by public access to
information so a very good judgment for
Health and Safety mister why is it so
important to find out what is in the
studies what do you expect to find out
about glyphosate obviously none of the
four of us is a toxicologist and the
whole point is that the science by
nature has to be peer-reviewed and since
some of the data and studies remain
confidential
according to FCC a previous decision
which was now annulled it's impossible
for the scientific community to conduct
a peer review and now this is all going
to be possible and this will definitely
add trust to the decisions that public
authorities are are taking but didn't
the European Commission already declared
this weedkiller safer you saying you
don't trust that decision yeah that's
that's the whole point that of course
and if we have access to that
information which then can be reassessed
and double-checked by the scientific
community and researchers then then I
would say that the trust will be there
so as it was mentioned there was a
controversial assessment by two
different bodies in this question and
that of course raises questions and and
question questions that must be
addressed by by a further scientific
assessment and I believe that FS are
actually also understands that such
transparency is key to public trust and
it's a very important public authority
and I hope that they will take due
attention to do this judgment so this is
about transparency about public interest
what do you think this ruling today
could actually change on the ground in
the way that glyphosate is used I don't
think there will be any change on the
ground unless there's a very strong
public attention and maybe more
national restrictions to the use and
there have been national restrictions on
close to two kindergartens in public
places but the real thing will in my
view come when the Commission has to
look at the the continuation of the
permit of glyphosate and that comes in
in a few years time so then certainly
this ruling has an importance because
then the scientific community will have
a much better chance to see that things
go right and that the the scientific
assessment of glyphosate is correct
alright hidy-ho taylor a member of the
european parliament for the green party
thank you very much for joining us thank
you